- C'est dans cette petite ville
sous contrôle ukrainien,
à 230 km de Marioupol,
que les rescapés
reprennent leur souffle.
Anna savoure ses premiers
moments de calme, de soleil
avec ses enfantst t sa mère.
Après 57 jours passés sous
terre, le petit Yvan, un an et
demi, ne marche plus tout seul;
il a constamment besoin
d'être rassuré.
"On a encore très peur, dit
Anna. Dès qu'on entend un t,t,t,
on veut se mettre à l'abri.
C'était terrible! Je ne sais pas
comment on a réussi à endurer
tout ça."
"Moi, j'ai vécu ma vie,
j'ai 66 ans, nous dit sa mère,
mais je pleurais pour eux,
pour les enfants. Je me disais :
leur vie va se terminer si vite!
Alors, j'essayais d'inventer
des jeux pour les réconforter."
Sur ces images prises plus tôt
par les soldats ukrainiens,
on voit l'abri où était Anna.
Ils étaient 30 dans la noirceur,
privés de tout.
Voici où elle vivait,
dans une pièce humide. Son fils
est là, sous les couvertures.
Il n'y avait pas de couche :
elle a fabriquait avec
des bouts de vêtements
et des sacs de plastique.
"C'était inconfortable
pour lui", dit-elle.
On voit aussi les militaires
leur distribuer de
la nourriture; c'est ce qui
leur a permis de survivre.
Cette femme, épuisée,
avait lancé cet appel à l'aide.
Natalia est, elle aussi, saine
et sauve. Elle n'en revient pas
encore d'avoir finalement pu
échapper à l'horreur.
"On voyait rarement la lumière,
dit-elle. Quand on montait
les escaliers, c'était
trop dangereux, on était tout
le temps bombardé et on pouvait
se faire tuer. Alors, on restait
en bas, à trembler de peur."
Dans le cauchemar de
cette guerre, les rescapés
de l'usine d'Azovstal ont eu
de la chance, en tout cas,
jusqu'à ce que la Russie
encercle l'aciérie, parce
qu'ils étaient mieux protégés
qu'ailleurs à Marioupol.
Ils étaient dans les abris
les plus résistants,
les plus profonds de la ville,
et c'est pour ça qu'ils ont été
si nombreux à s'y réfugier.
On le voit bien ici :
construits à l'ère soviétique,
ces repaires souterrains
ont plusieurs étages.
La plupart des civils
sont les enfants, les familles
d'ouvriers de l'aciérie, arrivés
au tout début du conflit;
d'autres sont des proches
des militaires.
Le fils de Natalia
est toujours là-bas.
Elle pleure en pensant à lui.
"Mon fils est dans le régiment
Azov, dit-elle. Il est resté
pour défendre l'usine d'Azovstal
avec les blessés. Il y a encore
beaucoup de gens, des civils
qui n'ont pas pu être évacués."
Le mari d'Anna est aussi
un combattant. Elle l'a revu
une dernière fois trois jours
avant son évacuation.
"Bien sûr, c'est très dur,
dit-elle. J'espère que la Croix-
Rouge et l'ONU vont pouvoir
faire sortir les civils,
mais les militaires aussi.
Quand on s'est dit au revoir,
on ne pensait pas qu'on ne se
reverrait plus."
(rires)
Elle espère bien sûr qu'ils se
retrouveront, pour ses enfants
surtout. Mais le combat
est inégal à Azovstal
et son issue pour les assiégés
ne fait plus beaucoup de doute.
Ici Céline Galipeau,
Radio-Canada, Zaporijia.